well there is still a widespread belief
out there particularly on the right that
business interests are basically
conservative and you could argue about
whether that was ever true it's
certainly not true now the opposite is
true the ideological gap between the
leaders of America's most powerful
corporations and say the Democratic
Party is basically non-existent they
agree on everything
now having failed at the ballot box in
2016 the left is using other means to
make the outcome of those elections
irrelevant in fact nowhere is this clear
that on the subject of the Second
Amendment there is a constitutional
right to bear arms in the Bill of Rights
number two in most states there's not a
lot of enthusiasm for restricting the
Second Amendment voters don't want it
doesn't matter the left is now colluding
with large companies to rollback your
rights to bear arms without any
legislation or all no public debate that
is doing it for example on the website
reddit the page for gun deals has been
banned can't go there anymore on YouTube
Google has banned the postings of videos
at linked to gun sellers or that simply
promote the purchase of guns or
accessories like magazines they also ban
videos demonstrating how to attach gun
accessories already popular YouTube
firearm channels have been banned driven
off or demonetised you can't find them
you can't get the information anymore
but the most amazing example of this
comes from Citibank now that company
announced today it will require all of
its clients to block gun sales to those
under 21 to bar the sale of bump stocks
or high-capacity magazines
you may remember Citigroup because about
ten years ago they got forty five
billion of your dollars taxpayer dollars
to get bailed out that's why they still
exist now they turn around and work to
undermine the constitutional rights of
the taxpayers who bailed them out we
called Citibank today to ask if they'd
send a representative over to explain
how this works exactly but they refused
because they're cowards this is
happening over and over more companies
are participating and they're taking
action on more issues the fear the
government might remove your rights is
becoming quaint big tech and big finance
are doing it for them already with no
public debate they just do it and tough
luck if you don't like it Larry Keene
president of the National Shooting
Sports Foundation he joins us tonight
Larry thanks a lot for coming on this
Tucker this is
one of those changes that I don't think
anybody anticipated was coming and it's
not exactly clear what the parameters
are YouTube is banning what well they're
banning any advertising or videos
involving firearms it sorts a little
unclear and it's very vague about the
scope so for example are they gonna ban
videos of teaching you how to reload
ammunition which as you know is very
common the United States or firearm
safety education videos that show people
how to use firearms so it's very
troubling that YouTube would censor
information as a as a media entity you
would think that they would be a little
bit more sensitive to the consequences
of censorship so very troubling what
they're engaged in but but more than
just a media entity I mean this is not
like Fox News The Washington Post thing
we're not going to cover something I
mean YouTube is the public square in
effect if you have and they have a
massive share of online videos if they
shut down a whole category then it's
kind of over isn't it yeah I mean as you
say they're like the you know that's the
free market of ideas except they have a
monopolistic power and they're putting a
finger on the scale and deciding what
information Americans are allowed to see
so they're suppressing First Amendment
rights and at the same time they're
suppressing the Second Amendment rights
by preventing people from gathering or
acquiring information about a completely
lawful activity and firearms are
protected by the Constitution of the
United States so it's deeply troubling
and I think that the public is going to
be very upset about it and we're
certainly going to be talking to members
of Congress to have oversight hearings
to find out exactly what these social
media sites are doing and how they're
abusing their mapa listing power on
information to advance a liberal agenda
Republicans seem to think this is an
example of the free market but there's
nothing free about this market at all
it's controlled Larry thank you I
appreciate that you're spend time with
you thank you antwuan see right is
founder and CEO blueprint strategy and
he joins this night antwuan thanks for
coming on I'm sure you agree with the
aims of Citibank and of YouTube and a
Facebook and I mean you share the same
politics as most CEOs of these companies
but does it feel strange for you as
someone on the left to find yourself in
curry
King corporate power shutting down
ordinary people the left was never for
that why are they for that now well
before I'm on the left before I'm
anything political Tucker I'm a human
being and what I do more is I know what
it's like to I know but let me finish I
know what it's like to have to bury
someone who you love due to being killed
in a church in Charleston as I
experienced almost three years ago I
also know what it feels like to see a
do-nothing Congress and elected leaders
across this country both at the national
and local level not Act after we've had
these senseless shootings mass shootings
we've had in this country so I
appreciate the courage of the business
community of business leaders who have
stepped up to say you know what if
Congress in Washington DC does not want
to do anything if General Assemblies
across the country do not want to do
anything then less lead by example let's
be on the right side of history okay do
something that the people we serve want
to do because the truth of the matter is
so you agree with masters that democracy
is stupid and why would you gonna are
you gonna let me finish are you gonna
continue to talk loud and think that
that's like no thing to do here's the
bottom line
I appreciate these people for having
courage stepping up to the plate and
acting on something that the people who
occupy their businesses want 70% of this
cut people in this country Democrat and
Republican wants something done and let
me ask you a question I'm gonna okay so
do you're happy now that the unelected
functionaries at the world's largest
companies happen to agree with you
they're doing something that you want
but what if they took a position that
you're not in favor of what if they said
I don't know pick something black lives
matter is bad we're not going to let any
more black lives matter videos on
YouTube we're not Citibank
won't process any payment to black lives
matter you so we'll wait a second you
control all credit cards you control all
videos and you shut this down maybe you
might feel differently can you see why
there's perhaps a flipside to this
of course I can and that has happened in
many instances but here the beauty about
living and here's the beauty about
living in the United States of America
we have the ability to disagree with
people who may not agree with us and the
truth be told if you don't agree with
YouTube if you do not agree with Dick's
Sporting Goods at Walmart or any of
these corporations who have acted in
this manner of trying to reduce another
incident for happening and then don't
shop with them do not ask you let me ask
you so if I don't agree with Google
which has a complete monopoly over all
human information it has a 90% monopoly
on search for example so everything we
know basically comes from Google if I
don't agree with them I don't really
have a lot of places to go I mean
nothing gets DuckDuckGo as a liberal
does this level of corporate power this
concentration of power in the hands of a
very small number of rich people that
doesn't bother you at all well I'm not a
liberal I think I'm Antoine Seawright a
person who has a political opinion as a
father I'm a tree I agree I agree with
corporations who are stepping up to the
plate answering the call that some of
our elected officials do not have the
courage to do could there be a downside
to settling problems would have various
when the richest people in the world
gets together and say we're going to
impose this on a society that's better
than having elected officials vote to do
something through the democratic process
is that what you're saying what I'm
saying you tucker is the fact that we
are three years from charleston six
months from vegas a month or so from
parkland and i don't know how long from
some of the other math students we've
had and nothing has been done in the
name of trying to change the shaman so
therefore if no Tucker you know as well
as I know that if a small group of
people get together that number will
grow and something can be done and I
think that's what's happened it's not
even races are going to be on the right
side okay yeah we'll see Antoine thank
you appreciate it how about reasonable
people Tucker